good evening we start tonight with some
breaking news and u.s. media are
reporting that basketball star Kobe
Bryant has died in a helicopter crash in
California LA County Sheriff's
Department say that all five people on
board a helicopter have died in a crash
and an investigation is ongoing into the
cause of it well a shahuri nag joins me
now so Ashley what do we know about the
helicopter crash so far essentially we
understand that helicopter has crashed
in Calabasas near Los Angeles in
California it's believed that five
people were on board and we're hearing
that celebrity news site
TMZ are reporting that the basketball
player Kobe Bryant was on board as one
of those five people who have been
confirmed to have died he is one of the
most famous basketball players in the
world 41 year old man he's a father of
four we understand it
his most recent child was born in June
2019 only last year it's understood his
wife Vanessa and their four daughters
weren't on board and as I say one of the
greatest NBA players of all time is what
he's known as and he's used to doing
this commute very often he's used to
using his helicopter going back and
forth between bitter punditry going to
sea games so we're waiting to see
whether that's fully confirmed well
that's right as you say it's us media
reporting at this News at the moment and
these pictures coming in to us now are
showing emergency responders at the
scene of a helicopter crash in
California lost in Los Angeles County
emergency responders there at the scene
and we have heard as you were saying
there as nough from Los Angeles County
Sheriff as saying that five people have
died in a crash in Calabasas but they
haven't identified the victims
themselves how they that the the reports
are coming from the media in America to
suggest that the basketball player was
on board that absolutely yeah we
understand it's his private helicopter
and but we're yet to as you say confirm
whether that's that's the case whether
he was on board